hey baby we have to leave in like ten
minutes for the party okay no I'm just
gonna use a mouthwash it's perfectly
fine that one doesn't kill all the germs
in your breath it's true no mouthwash
has been proven to kill like 99% of
bacteria it does a great job really
bless your tune
okay how about this I will make a video
on mouthwash versus toothpaste and then
we'll see it was right okay in this
video I'll be testing to see which
method is most efficient at cleaning
your mouth brushing your teeth or using
mouthwash I'll be using tryptic soy agar
petri dishes to grow bacteria that i've
swab from my mouth this particular
growth media selects gram positive
bacteria to grow on it the most common
bacteria present in your oral cavity is
called streptococcus mutans which is the
gram positive species we'll be trying to
grow in total I'll be conducting three
experiments for each experiment I'll eat
a milk chocolate candy bar right before
I go to bed the chocolate has a ton of
sugar in it and will help bacteria grow
in my mouth
overnight oh and I won't be cleaning my
teeth after eating the candy bar as I
have to allow the bacteria to grow when
I wake up in the morning I'm going to
swab three different areas of my mouth
to collect bacterial samples
specifically I'll be swabbing my front
teeth my teeth in the back of my mouth
by my molars and my gums on the left
side of my mouth on day one for the
first experiments I'm going to swab the
three areas of my mouth without
performing any kind of dental cleaning
this experiment will be the control and
will allow us to see how much bacteria
grows when I don't clean my mouth on day
two before I swab I'll brush my teeth
for two minutes which by the way is the
suggested duration of time by the
American Dental Association and finally
on day three I'll use mouthwash for two
minutes and then swab I used a
sterilized inoculation loop before each
sample collection and stored the petri
dishes in an incubator at 37 degrees
Celsius in complete darkness for 24
hours here's the results first let's
start with the control plate
culture and the top left area of the
plate is from my teeth in the front of
my mouth
the top right is from my teeth in the
back of my mouth and the bottom is from
my gums one thing that's really
interesting that I didn't expect to see
was the amount of bacteria present in
the different areas of my mouth it
appears that my teeth in the back of my
mouth have more bacteria than in the
front this is evident because the
culture on the right has a more
blanketed covering appearance on the
surface while the culture on the left
has more individually isolated colonies
I attribute more bacteria being present
in the back of my mouth because I like
most people rarely brushed that far back
as a result there's more bacteria there
and then in the front let's look at the
mouthwash plate
compared to the control there is
definitely less bacteria but with still
a fair amount present if mouthwash kills
99% of bacteria then why is there still
so much here if you think you have the
answer then post in the comments how
about the toothbrush played this shows a
dramatic drop in bacteria compared to
the control and especially to the
mouthwash blade I have to say though I'm
not entirely surprised that the
toothbrush removed more bacteria than
the mouthwash did it's true that
mouthwash is a strong antiseptic and
does kill 99% of bacteria in your mouth
the active ingredients eucalyptol
menthol and methyl salicylate are all
very strong antibacterial agents but the
99% of bacteria that are killed are
mostly free-moving non colonized
bacteria the bacteria that remain in
your mouth after using mouthwash have
colonized your teeth these bacteria form
thick hardy layers of biofilm that
protect them from damage in case you're
wondering this bacteria is plaque
mouthwash can't remove plaque because
it's friendly attached to the surface of
your teeth the only way to get rid of it
is to physically scrape or brush it off
which is why brushing and flossing is so
effective also one additional thing that
toothpaste does that mouthwash doesn't
is it neutralizes acid secreted by
bacteria when bacteria breaks down sugar
in your mouth it secretes a byproduct
called lactic acid this acid is what
eats away at the calcium in your teeth
causing cavities to counteract this acid
toothpaste contains a basic substance
called calcium carbonate which
neutralizes the acid by the way if
you've ever eaten something sweet like
candy or chocolate and then a half-hour
later your mouth has a bitter aftertaste
it's because the bacteria in your mouth
are converting the sugar into acid
causing the bitter taste okay okay you
made your point I'm brushing your teeth
two or maybe three times
it kills way more bacteria this is
technically a good point
what if it just takes a couple more
swishes of mouthwash to detach the
plaque from your teeth well I try this
too
in the first experiment using mouthwash
i gargle for two minutes for the second
mouthwash experiment I used to separate
caps of mouthwash and gargled for two
minutes each reaching a total of four
minutes of mouthwash do my experiment
here's the results surprisingly there is
a drop in bacteria after using mouthwash
for a longer period of time
this shows that mouthwash may be
somewhat effective in reducing plaque
when used for long periods one thing I
noticed that I can't explain is there
appears to be less bacteria from the
back of my mouth than there is in the
front I'm not sure as to why this is so
if you have a theory please post in the
comments when comparing these results
with the toothbrush experiment it's
still apparent that brushing your teeth
is the better option even if you use
mouthwash for four minutes I was going
to try and do a six minute mouthwash
experiment but I started to feel a
really intense burning sensation in my
mouth by the fourth minute so I skipped
it entirely
in conclusion it's fairly obvious that
brushing your teeth is indeed the best
way to clean your mouth I'm sure that
you could gargle mouthwash for six or
even eight minutes and it may have equal
results to brushing your teeth however
you can get just as good results from
brushing your teeth with a fraction of
the time hey guys thanks for watching if
you're wondering about the t-shirt I was
wearing in the video I'm collaborating
with a very talented designer named
Mikkel all the way from Prague he set up
this cool merch shop with all kinds of
different questions for science t-shirts
hoodies mugs and posters you can check
it out by going to the link at the
bottom of the video or click the link in
the description I'd also like to take a
second to thank my very generous patrons
who helped support this and future
videos as always thanks for watching and
stay tuned